[Music]
there was a bear on the loose in a
suburb of LA and just a couple days ago
this bear got loose and the local news
was all over this story incredible
footage take a look it was a brown bear
got loose was walking around climbing
fences going into people's yards
wandering around alleyways and so animal
control I finally arrived they
tranquilized the bear and he's fine
released him back into the wild but
because this happened we've been asked
to remind you as a public service and
this goes for everyone in the country
because summer is coming and with summer
almost here let us just tell you if you
do encounter a bear do not disturb it ok
just let the bear do what it's going to
do until Animal Control gets there leave
it alone let it do what its gonna do
that is very good advice you do not want
to bear to feel threatened you just need
to okay any turn turn turn around turn
around turn on the guy oh my I just
can't get over here okay stay calm and
Lydia Missy let the bear do what its
gonna do just relax
what stay calm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm really sorry Liz
maybe you shouldn't just let the bear do
what it wants to do well that guys still
at my podium I forgot about yeah that's
easy to it this is a whole new show
[Applause]
[Music]